flawed male characters versus flawed
female characters how are they different
I think that male characters are the
only thing I can speak about with great
accuracy I don't think there's a sex
based distinction between the two I
think however I believe women are are
generally more physically afraid of the
world and if you're gonna write a great
female character you need to understand
that women walk around scared a lot of
the time most men don't understand that
if you want to write a great character
that's not your sex you've got to
somehow learn about that sex just as I
think a lot of women writers don't write
great male characters because we are
very different so the best writers on
television a Matt Winer Matt Winer
writes great female characters he
obviously understands who they are and
then you have another side of it there
are some writers I'm not going to name
them who write Fantastic shows about the
Old West or whatever and and their male
characters are extremely well realized
but the women are basically they're
either or they're they're their
vehicles for what they say I don't think
most I think most writers can do one or
the other really well I think Matt Winer
does them both really well it's a
question of understanding the other sex
and most writers have difficulty
empathizing with with people that aren't
like themselves and again this is why
core wounds matter because you cannot as
a writer if you don't empathize and
really understand the character you're
writing about you're gonna write a
cliche and I think that some writers
simply specialize in either female or
male and I love that the female
characters that that whiner shows us
have a depth and a
vulnerability that that I don't think
even a great writer okay I'm gonna say
it I mean I think David Milch is a
fabulous writer huh I think he's he's a
genius a Shakespearean genius but I
think he is male characters have a sort
of a of a depth and a believability that
I don't know that he always brings to
women it doesn't really matter because
his worlds are so great and then you
pick the world that you're going to be
able to to render the Old West is a
man's world okay so that's that's a good
place for him to be Matt whiners world
early 60s is a man's world with women
coming into it so that's a good world
for him to be in how do we know if we've
written a cliche I people will not be
interested in the character and they
will write you a note like he's not
sympathetic whenever you get a note like
he's not sympathetic what it really
means is he's not believable why are we
sympathetic to a character because we
understand him that's why confession is
important but having sympathy for a
character we can sympathize with a
complete a whole but it has to be
believable right so when somebody gives
you a note characters not sympathetic
don't understand what they're really
saying is they're boring again figure
out why they're acting the way they do
and look at why they're damaged give
yourself five ways a character is
compensating for their wound that's
always a way to make them believable to
make them deep
you